hello everyone and welcome to the uh
Spanish league this is the honor
division of the Spanish league and it is
pregnant versus Ivan chaparino it's the
first game that we are going to cover a
lot we have requested it as it's a
really incredible over 100 moves and the
game really shows just how much you have
to invest in a game and how much you
have to
be excellent for like six hours in order
to defeat an opponent who just will not
blunder uh so let's dive straight into
it it is pregnant with the white pieces
and he opens with E4 I would cover this
game sooner but yesterday I was picking
grapes with some friends and well the
wine is not just gonna make itself will
it so E4 yeah we have C5 Bain even going
for the Sicilian Defense Knight F3 D6
and now Knight the C3 we have Knight to
F6 and now D4 so uh winning with that D4
push for one move C characters Knight
captures sorry not Knight captures Queen
captures actually in this game so Prague
deviates uh and it's uh well uh night
counter Sunday for is very very standard
everyone plays at Queen captures and D4
is much rarer and after Knight the C6
usually you will see Bishop to be B
Bishop to B5 here but Prague does not go
Bishop to B5 he goes Queen to E3
sometimes the queen goes to D3 but E3 uh
is uh again very rare it can be played
but uh you know it leaves the question
unanswered where do you develop your
pieces like what are you going to do
with your dark dark Square Bishop so
okay G6 even obviously also very happy
to find out with Bishop to C4 and now
Bishop to G7 we have H3 and both players
Castle so castles castles and now there
are some games where A6 was played also
you can go Knight to A5 you can go after
the bishop you can re-maneuver this
Knight to D7 then the E5 or C5 but here
we have Queen to C7 and it is now
already as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game okay Ponte A4 we
have Ponte A6 and queen to E2 now Prague
shows us how he will develop his dark
Square Bishop we have Ponte E6 and the
bishop to E3 we have Pawn to B6 uh
preparing the Finca to the bishop to B7
this might however leave the A6 Pawn a
little bit weak but you have to develop
this way we'll Rook after D1 and now
Bishop to B7 we have Bishop to F4
putting pressure on that D6 pawn and
this can be treated many different ways
you can go Knight to a five foot
pressure on the bishop you can just
defend the pawn uh even goes for Knight
to E5 this is how he defends and also
the bishop is now hanging so Bishop back
to B3 and just Rook after d8 so nothing
um uh nothing no no problems for black
here he is preparing Pawn to D5 so Rook
to D2 Prague wants to double up on the D
file and now Knight F to D7 uh we have
Knight captures and E5 product trades
once we have D captures on E5 and Bishop
to G5 attacking the rook and now Knight
to F6 so uh Prague was able to ruin even
spawn structure a little bit but still
this ruined Pawn structure gives him
excellent central control Toro capture
78 Rook capture 78 and now Bishop to C4
trying to take advantage of the
undefended A6 Pawn is defended once but
it is attacked twice so you have to do
something about this queen to C8 yeah
it's a good a good
a position for Prague because the queen
is much less active on C8 than cheese
and C7 In the Sicilian uh C7 square is
sort of a standard for for the black
queen so Bishop back to D3 now the E4
Pawn is the the defendant end proc can
look to improve the position of his
other pieces with Rook to D4 a very nice
Rook lift trying to get practical for
Bishop to E3 and that's exactly what
Prague goes for Bishop to E3 Rook to D6
defending and now Rook to D1 we have
Knight to D7 now preparing Knight to C5
and Here pawn to F3 a further defending
the E for Pawn Knights the C5 and now
Bishop back to C4 of course not allowing
trade a knight for Bishop as both of
them still have the bishop pair so now
you have to be a little bit careful uh
if the queen for example moves you're
just gonna pick up the Knight and then
win the A6 spawn so here chaparin of
Trades once with Rook captures Queen
captures and now all of his pieces are
accidentally placed the queen is great
the bishop is great and nice great the
bishop and G7 not so great so he will
improve on that Bishop to f8 uh Queen to
E2 again uh putting pressure on that A6
pawn and Bishop to E7 now we have Pawn
to B3 and pawn to H5 so Japanese says
all right you've made some some nice
ideas here some nice moves uh but how
are you uh looking for for any advantage
here so Knights to D1 and now Knight
back to D7 we have King to H2 King to G7
both players just improved the position
of their kings and queen to uh D2 now
with some ideas of maybe bishop to H6
check if the position calls for it but
nothing really happening here Queen to
C6 we have Queen back to E2 again
putting pressure on the A6 Pawn saying
your queen cannot remain on the active
C6 Square so he goes back Queen to C8
and now Knight to F2 we have Knight back
to C5 King to H1 and now Queen to C7 and
queen back to D2 uh Queen to D2 is sort
of there hoping that chaparino is not
satisfied with the draw and that he
still wants to continue playing this
game and he does he goes Knight captures
on A4 now of course if the Knight is
captured the bishop will hang so proc
plays Bishop characters on E6 and
chaparino says alright thank you for
that you've um eliminated that doubled E
Pawn uh Knight back to C5 attacks the
bishop but now Prague gets the D5 Square
for his Bishop which was impossible with
the pawn on E6 so Pawn to A5 and now
Knight to D3 putting pressure on the the
C5 Knight end on the E5 pawn and just
Knight captures on the three Queen
captures and here Bishop captures on D5
was played now the reason you capture on
D5 is uh Prague already has a threat
here let's say you play H4 which is a
great move prague's idea was of course
Bishop capture some B7 and after Queen
captures Queen B5 just going after the
B6 pawn and you cannot defend Bishop to
C5 will of course be met with Bishop
captures and you will not be able to
recapture as the queen is hanging so you
have to go after the C2 Pawn but the
problem is after Bishop captures and
queen captures and see do you have Queen
captures an E5 check and prog wins upon
Bishop F6 Queen gets nicely nicely
centralized on D5 and after A4 okay you
can trade everything off here your
Prague still ends the position being up
a pawn uh probably not enough to win the
game but still you know uh it's uh
giving up a pawn so chaparino decides to
capture Bishop capture spawn characters
and now just block the block the
position with Bishop to D6 so okay prago
C4 we have Pawn to F5 and now Bishop to
D2 We have Queen to C5 and queen to E3
offering a queen trade and chaparino
says all right we've played this game
quite enough let's trade and uh call
this a day uh with Bishop the C7 just
the sorry not Bishop to C7 Bishop to C5
defending and offering a trade if you
trade of course it's it's a draw nothing
really happening here yes you do have a
pass d-pawn but the blacking will just
blockade it and that's pretty much it so
if Prague wants to continue he has to
keep the Bishops in the game Bishop G5
now comes King F7 with Pawn to G4 uh
Bishop the east 7 again offering a trade
of Bishops with Bishop back to D2 and
now Bishop to C5 with King to G2 and now
chaparino trades wants characters
captures and King the E7 we have King to
G3 and Bishop to D4 now uh King to H4
and now King to F6 with Bishop to G5
check King F7 and here proc trades
captures captures and now uh once you
look at this position you you probably
think okay I mean still it's a dead raw
both players equal material both players
the Bishops of the dark Square collar uh
prox King may be a little bit more
active but certainly not enough to
influence the result or anything but
there's one thing that you always have
to check when you're playing the end
game of the Bishops of the same color
look at prague's pawns prox pawns are on
light squares all of them and uh even
has a dark Square Bishop so even if you
give black 1000 moves with the bishop uh
the result he cannot change the position
or anything because the pawns are on
light squares and here on the other hand
has three points on dark squares which
proc can attack as he also has a dark
Square Bishop so uh oh okay you can't
really attack the A5 Pawn but this is
the base of the pawn chain you can
attack this pawn and you can attack this
on so this is the next stage of products
plan King H5 with Bishop to C5 and now
Bishop to H4 with Bishop act E3 and now
Bishop to d8 now the we're gonna
position the bishop to C7 to put
pressure on both of these pawns we have
King to G7 cutting off the white king
from entering the game now comes Bishop
to G5 first offering a trade now it
would be great for Prague if the bishops
get traded off but just Bush it back to
C5 with Bishop to H4 King to F7 and now
Bishop to G5 with Bishop to F2 and now
Prague has to go for this setup Bishop
d8 Bishop to E3 and Bishop to C7 so now
he puts pressure on the B6 and the E5
pawns and of course King to F6 nothing
to worry about here Bishop to D6 and now
Bishop to F2 with the should actor B8
Bishop to C5 and now Bishop to C7 so how
is he to make progress here with Bishop
to E3 Bishop to D6 and just Bishop to F2
with Bishop to A3 now Bishop to E3 and
now a bishop B2 putting pressure on this
Pawn so you have to be a little bit
careful if the bishop moves maybe some
F4 ideas
uh can happen but Bishop D4 offers the
queen trade Bishop to C1 and now Bishop
to F2 with Bishop D2 Bishop to D4 and
now Bishop to E1 with Bishop to C5 and
now Bishop to C3 with Bishop to D4 and
of course Prague declines this with
Bishop to F2 and Bishop to C1 with
Bishop back to D4 and the bishop to G5
check now King to F7 and now Bishop to
H4 one thing you can never allow the
white king is to touch the G6 square if
the wild king touches the G6 Square uh
then you've allowed too much and it's
game over so Bishop to C5 Bishop back to
G3 putting pressure on the Pawn King F6
with Bishop to E1 Bishop to E3 and now
Bishop to H4 with check King to F7 and
the bishop to d8 now uh we have King to
G7 and Bishop to E7 King F7 Bishop to D6
and now King to F6 and here Prock plays
Bishop to C7 and now this is a beautiful
position uh where uh I mean it's a great
wait for Prague but if even plays a
precise moves then it will be a draw of
course but look at this the this Pawn is
attacked this Pawn is attacked the king
can't really move or as only the king is
defending the E5 Pawn so what can you
play here well the move you have to play
here and just give you an example if you
play something like Bishop to D4 you
want to not move anything uh then comes
the bishop to d8 check and here's the
problem King F7 King to G5 and now you
will have to move either the E4 Pawn or
the F4 Pawn but it doesn't matter
already here white is completely winning
so the move you have to find here as
even is Pawn to E4 but it was not played
in the game in the game Pawn the F4 was
played it's a hard to make a choice
really the point after E4 is that after
captress and captures and King G4 you
can play Bishop to G1 and you can't
really uh play King F4 then the then the
pawn comes to E3 and if you play Bishop
to F4 now of course if the pawn is
Advanced You'll Play King to F3 now just
gonna play Bishop C5 and you will keep
the
uh white king cut off from the pawn
however in the game Ponte F4 was played
and this is now a little bit different
now we have King to G4 Bishop to C5 and
now Bishop to d8 with check King to G6
and now Bishop to H4 so again not really
a lot of moves for the black king you
you cannot allow King to five so Bishop
to D6 and now Bishop to G5 Bishop to f8
and Bishop to d8 now attacking the pawn
here and Bishop to C5 defending the pawn
so what has changed in this position
well a lot actually feel free to pause
the video and win the game for Prague
while I give you a couple of seconds
sorry if I'm a bit red I I really got a
lot of sun yesterday uh you know
during the grape picking
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show uh it is Pawn to D6 if
you found this you are of course a true
Master of the end game there is one
other way you could do this you could go
Bishop to H4 and then wait for black to
make a move after black makes a movie
will play Bishop death during the when
black defends the pawn now you can play
C5 this is also a way to do it as you
gotta pass the d-pawn but the prague's
solution is much more elegant look at
this these six Bishop captures and D6
and now Bishop capture some B6 and now
instead of having to pass the d-pawn
which had to cross through these dark
squares now you have the past C Pawn
which has to cross these two dark
squares which are defended and now price
of force idea is just Advanced upon and
win the game but you have to be careful
the black king is very close to the
action so the black king can stop those
pawns if you push too quickly so Bishop
to B4 was played and now not C5 but
rather Bishop to d8 first stop them
black king from uh going Queen side via
the F6 square and if black king goes
King F7 then you get the F5 square and
we already said if the white king
touches F5 it's a game over so Bishop to
C3 we have pawned the C5 now into F7 you
have to move the king now comes King to
F5 finally Prague wins the F5 Square
King to E8 and Bishop to C7 we have King
to D7 and Bishop captures on E5 with
Bishop to B4 going after the C5 pawn and
prog trades the pawns with Bishop
captures and F4 and Bishop captures and
C5 so now Prague is up a pawn uh can he
win this well let's see Bishop to D2
goes after the pawn and Bishop to B6 so
now the bishop is stuck on this diagonal
guarding the A5 Pawn King E4 with King
to C6 and now Pawn to F4 with Bishop to
d8 pawn to F5 with King to B5 and now uh
the idea is of course that if uh Prague
gives even a chance he will just trade
pawns here and he will sacrifices Bishop
for the F6 Pawn if needed and it will be
a draw by insufficient material and here
the the pressure obviously got the prog
the winning move here is King to E5 but
probably King to D5 and he allowed even
back into the game now the difference is
this because after King to E5 a look at
this King to C5 you're going to play
Bishop to C3 King to C6 and now King the
E6 and you don't really have a good way
of advancing The Pawn King to B5 You're
Gonna Play Bishop to F6 cut off the
Bishop from the from touching these two
squares Bishop to B6 and now you're
gonna play Bishop to E5 if Bishop back
to d8 you will play Bishop to D6 and
next Bishop to E7 will be played and the
uh Black's dark Square Bishop will not
be able to help out with the stopping of
the pawn and the dark squares however
here proc played King the D5 and now he
allows him to go Bishop to F6 King the
E6 and now Bishop to D4 and now it's
much much harder here of course if you
play F6 right to wait then like we said
you just give up material and play Ponte
A4 and even if you play Pawn to B4 yes
the pawn is defended A3 and you cannot
stop this A2 doesn't really matter what
you play King D5 you will give up the
pawn bishop captures King characters on
B4 and again a draw by insufficient
material so after Bishop to D4 King to
D6 was played and now Bishop to B2 now
how are you winning this game well
you're not so after King to D5 we've
Bishop back to F6 Bishop to E1 and now
Bishop to G7 they're just no good way to
do it uh King to E4 Bishop to F6 with
King to D3 and now Bishop to G5 with
Bishop to C3 and just Bishop to E7 and
uh this bishop to E7 is the move that
allows proc to win the game once more uh
the move you have to play is Bishop to
d8 but it's such a uh such a silly uh
position that the problem the real
problem is that that proc can play this
position indefinitely he just has to be
careful not to repeat moves and hope his
opponent does not make the perfect move
every time and this is uh one such
possession where Bishop to D draws the
game but Bishop this uh E7 does not as
it will give the white king a valuable
Tempo uh when marching forward so now we
have King to E4 and Bishop to G5 the
problem is if you play A4 here uh look
at this uh characters character is now
King to D5 and now this Tempo comes in
really handy uh King B5 King the E6
attacks the bishop Bishop to A3 now F6
and after we bring the king closer F7
King to C7 you can't really bring the
king any closer now Bishop to F6
followed by Bishop to E7 and you go
Bishop to f8 now comes to Bishop to E7
Bishop to H6 and now okay you control
this Square now it's time to control
these two squares you will play King F5
and after King to D7 Bishop to A3 again
cutting off the black king completely
and after King to C6 or anything you're
just gonna play King to G6 and now you
are controlling these three squares next
move you are advancing the pawn the
victory so after King D4 Bishop the G5
was played by Evan trying to hold on but
now King to D5 Bishop to H4 and King to
E6 with Bishop to G5 Bishop to F6 and
now Bishop to D2 with Bishop to E7
Bishop to C3 and now Bishop to A3
cutting off the uh black king completely
here the opponent Bishop create a wall
here Bishop to G7 and here okay you
don't have to do it the usual way you
can actually play Pawn to F6 here this
is what product played and he was in
this position and move 114 that even
ciparino resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so the
the reason for this is that of course
the pawn is now becoming a queen and if
you trade and play A4 now the move that
wins the game is the move that almost
always wins the game and that is Pawn to
B4 now look at this King C4 King to E5
you're gonna play King to B3 but just
Pawn to B5 and believe it or not you are
one move short from getting a draw here
King captures You're Gonna Play B6 and
after the king moves you have to move
somewhere if you move here then the
white Pawn will Queen with checks so
you're gonna have to do it like this B7
A3 uh Queen and now King to A1 and yeah
like I said you are one uh a move short
from from getting a draw if this was the
position it would be a draw by stalemate
but now after King to D4 and pawn to A2
you will just move the queen allow the
king back into the game and once King B1
is played now comes King to D3 now of
course if you bring a Queen into the
game then Queen to C2 is Checkmate so
black will try to be tricky bringing a
knight into the game uh sometimes you
you have to use this like if you're
playing on leeches and your opponent has
like the one second uh and you you you
know that your opponent thinks that you
will just pre-move into a queen and he
will play Queen to C2 instantly and then
you will just get a draw but uh you know
uh if you want to be that kind of a
player but after King to C3 let's say
Knight to C2 you will just get
checkmated so I know some of you even
though when when it's winning you like
me to show how the game would end so
this is how the game would end but yeah
140 moves is what it took uh for proc to
take down even chaparinov and you see
that even though it was uh uh you know
an equal game uh if he has the engine
yeah it's a draw it's a draw all the
time but the problem is
um uh here like in this position where
where even before this like when uh
okay a lot of moves were played but uh
like even all the way here like when you
traded pawns it's only move 53 uh once
you realize that your opponent has
targets and you don't have targets you
know that you can play this forever that
play it forever if it's a classical
gameplay it forever and you know your
opponent will make a mistake eventually
uh so yeah that's the game I really hope
you guys enjoyed it uh I would like to
uh wish a very happy birthday to uh
Daniel Fajardo Jimenez uh and I would
like to thank Kim Coleman coming alimadi
and Raymond young for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it and I would like to
congratulate Draco uh who uh who
graduated in his university and as his
friends would say uh who who in their
right mind gave you gave you a diploma
uh sure I once again really hope you
guys enjoyed it um uh so you know you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
one of the suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and if you want to try your luck and
skill at playing alireza firuja first
link in the description below you
probably already know what I'm talking
about uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and sorry for a bit of a longer
video